pour moi c'est vraiment important dans
mon parcours des migrations alors
chantier en 2003 quand nous savons
commencé les dossiers pour migrer moi
j'ai parlé par français
des fleurs comestibles dans une salade
c'est délicieux mais c'est encore
meilleur avec de l'huile d'olive
TV5 qui on avait deux programmes du
Québec Radio-Canada et première émission
et l'épicerie et pour moi c'était très
important parce que de cette façon
j'avais la chance d'apprendre les
vocabulaire de fruits
végétaux et toutes les choses et la
cuisine voyez-vous par catégorie nous
donner des espoirs des suggestions
on n'avait pas d'internet ou de Facebook
ou des choses pour savoir ou avoir plus
d'informations par rapport à la place
comme vous voulez y aller
[Musique]
et votre métier est-ce qu'on a un lien à
voir avec ça oui vraiment et oui ici
j'ai changé de métiers j'ai commencé mon
petit entreprise de un panadas alpha
Rodez
tout si l'Argentine me faite ici et donc
de plus ça fait quelques années on était
choisi aussi par vous pour les missions
l'épicerie par rapport à les alfaroles
immigré au Québec il y a 12 ans Denise
Tilman et son mari roulianne Ruiz se
sont rapidement intégrés chez nous vous
étiez pâtissière en Argentine non non
j'ai travaillé dans une bureau comme
secrétaire de direction pour moi c'était
comme une film de Hollywood parce que je
vais venir de la de l'Amérique du Sud où
est-ce que je voyais toujours l'émission
l'épicerie et vous deux ensemble ils
étaient comme les rêves les rêves de
n'importe quel immigrants de dire
finalement je suis là dans l'émission où
est-ce que pour moi c'était les modèles
des commandes par les Français alors je
vous présente le restaurant patate et
percée avec sa magnifique terrasse ils
viennent du Liban de la Turquie de
l'Allemagne ou du Québec les kebabs ont
plusieurs personnalités et ils peuvent
être tous aussi succulents les uns que
les autres
[Musique]
je présente l'émission l'épicerie à mes
étudiants en francisation alors j'ai
préparé 6 questions ok en lien avec la
capsule est-ce que quelqu'un aimerait
lire la première question
Freddy s'il te plaît quel est le nom de
la franchise
un aliment de leur pays alors là je vois
les yeux qui s'illuminent les sourires
qui qui se font
c'est la découverte
d'ingrédients de leur pays dans des
reportages d'ici je trouve les Québécois
les capsules sont toujours bien faites
sont toujours pertinentes le débit est
parfait pour eux parce qu'ils apprennent
le français ce qui fait que ils sont
encore débutants dans l'apprentissage de
la langue ils doivent apprendre à
écouter en plus de parler à lire à
écrire donc c'est un bel exercice
d'écoute je pense qu'après à l'épicerie
ils sont un peu plus capable de poser
des questions
de reconnaître des aliments
donc resteront préférés et s'appelle
kimfun ok c'est où c'est dans
quartier chinois oui le quartier chinois
il y a beaucoup de teams ça doit être
délicieux oui au secondaire j'ai arrêté
complètement d'enseigné pendant presque
6 ans vous avez déjà mangé de la poutine
et puis je me suis retrouvé par hasard
en francisation il y avait une un
remplacement à faire et je me suis dit
mais pourquoi pas et j'apprends autant
que peuvent apprendre de moi
ce sont des gens qui ont un bagage qui
viennent d'un petit peu partout dans le
monde ce sont des gens qui vivent des
défis ce sont des gens extrêmement
reconnaissants
ce sont des gens qui partagent beaucoup
ma paye c'est quand les gens sont en
emploi et me disent madame j'ai trouvé
un emploi en français ça c'est ma paye